きたぞさあ
超吸水して昇給水性樹脂
おおおおう
持っていっ
これが多分これだわたぶんそれだてが競ってくれだこれじゃないと無理言ってに
リベンジする時がやってきましたこちら
超吸水性樹脂つなり数百倍量の水を吸収するみたいですというわけでぜにリベンジする
ときがやってきた吸水性ポリマーみたいなやつを買ったんですよ水を吸収して膨らむ
こんなそう思って僕が勝ってしまったか
全然違ったなんかねもう一買っておかないと味噌を吸収してフランコにならなかった
みたいなんですけどもこれは多分あってます絶対と数百倍の水を吸収できる不思議な高
分子化合物でで書いてありますから
ok 燃えるごみとして捨てるんだよね木の実を混ぜたらねあの前回の失敗で結構辛く
て
を辞めようかと思ったんですけどそこにみたいじゃ
ないですかこの赤さこんなの水を吸収して膨らむすがったよ一つ200グラム入ってる
ので
日揮は右の分ナッツを吸水性樹脂を準備しました今回こそやりましょう
これはお風呂にくっつくんですごい子なんだけどよく雨てでも荒れた配下に詰まったら
やべーな快感につまらないようでしょ
とりあえずちょっとこれが本当にそうなるかどうかっていうのを言ってさメスはもう
失敗は許されないから
持っています
お前がこいつで実験しましょうの実はこれで膨らむなかったらもうマジやばいよこれで
膨らまなくた俺の股間が福田ちょっと水をかけてみますあこれ膨らまないそう坊主に
なります
パンティーズができます
あっハックランダー膨らんで膨らんでる膨らんでる膨らんでる
をもうを背がめっちゃめっちゃ大きくなったらめっちゃ巨大化してますもう
あっ食べない方がいいかもすごいゼリーみたいに大きくなりました
いけるいけるいける億万できますはいけるいけるいける
今日は遠くたーーーー始めいよいよそう吸水性樹脂こちらを使って水を
数百倍を膨らむというあいまいな表現最低でも100万円の重要になるということなの
できゅう先生自社2kg 潰しているので簡単に計算すると見かける100
200グラムん
約2000はぁ
方の粉が取れまで大きくなるかという実験の書いてある通り水道んの対価に捨てちゃ
ダメなので祭すべてロックしてありますでは早速この犬でこうも心配に入れますよ
まあ待ってこの c 来なくな風アンマー吸い込まないほうがいい結果も入ってね
2kg の魔法の粉入れました
はいばっちり入っております背景下準備のモバツイでございます果たしてに水は100
倍以上吸収する不思議なこのはできるあるとどれくらいの出場になるのか
瑞佳里
さあ今入りましたぞおおすげえ固まってきている方が増えている
もうすげーすげーすげーまだ心についてことなんで送る
あっほど沿った場面全然の塊だんちょっといいかツアーでもうちょっと待ってみ
ましょう
女は阿部なくなかったね幌すごい是非みたいになっちゃったから
うわっすげ全然水を吸収しますかそしてどんな大きくなっていっております
果たしてこの子だわと思ってスクラムのでしょうか
マイケルぞ
うん
ああ超水ではないのでまだかろうじて劉秀オスれるみたいです
うわぁああこれまだ90できるとイカサマな硬いところがあるから食べまだ水を吸収
できるのお前だーなぁ
そうよちょっと限界まで水を吸収させてみましょう
pou dou dou
すげーいい
重い敗2分けで水を吸収するすぎなそんな
2kg に水を足した結果全然吸収しますと200件を超えている重さです
も扱いやすい a ななんかぜリーダーで入ってる人です
か続けどうしよっ
me